[Music]
hey this is a great question because
this actually really is a big problem in
space exploration all of the different
junk that's up there you know it's
actually the sixtieth anniversary of the
first satellite the United States ever
sent up called Explorer 1 so for more
than 60 years the earth has been putting
up satellites and robots and space
stations and all kinds of stuff up into
orbit and a lot of junk has accumulated
and sometimes it's just very small in
the early days of space exploration
sometimes they would even paint
satellites and all of those little paint
chips you know as things actually
degraded in space it's very cold it's
very dry up there after decades in space
the paint all chipped off and now there
are these tiny little things flying
around in orbit but the problem is is
that if you're in low-earth orbit by
definition you're traveling at about
17,000 miles an hour that's much much
much faster than a bullet comes out of a
gun so even a tiny little thing going at
that speed if it hits you in the wrong
direction it can cause huge amounts of
damage and in fact one of the things
that we do is actually study all the
debris up there at all the collisions
there's parts of the Hubble Space
Telescope that the astronauts have
actually brought back to earth and we
actually look at the metal and the
surfaces and think about all of the
little things that have hit we study how
much damage there is from all of the
debris up there some of the debris is
caused by humans you know bits of old
spacecraft and some of it is actually
natural there's just particles of dust
up there this is what creates meteors
right where people know if it's shooting
stars the earth accumulates about a
hundred tons every day of natural rock
and sandy stuff from space falling down
on us so some of the junk up there isn't
even human caused it's actually even
natural so what do you do with this
environment up there that's full of tiny
little things in some cases we actually
worry about the astronauts being hit by
these so if there's an astronaut out
doing a spacewalk they're in a
pressurized spacesuit and just like you
can't really make a tiny little hole in
a balloon if something actually got
through the spacesuit under pressure
that would be incredibly dangerous for
the astronaut so there are many things
up there that we track we're actually so
aware that space junk is becoming more
and more of a problem that we're really
encouraging other countries to be
all about what they do up in space a
couple years ago China as an experiment
actually collided two of their
satellites it was sort of a military and
space experiment and the amount of space
junk went up almost exponentially from
that from that one single event these
two satellites colliding all of this
different stuff went off into space so
some people have a job at NASA to
actually track the larger bits of space
junk and in some cases we know exactly
where they are and we can actually get
our satellites out of the way of them
even the International Space Station has
the ability to change its orbit just a
little bit and actually maneuver so
there's a particularly large piece of
space junk the space station may choose
to make little maneuvers to avoid it a
few times astronauts have actually been
a little bit worried there's been a tiny
tiny chance of a collision only a couple
percent but that's enough for us to be
concerned for them and in some cases
we've asked them to get ready for an
evacuation in case anything happened but
luckily nothing ever did so NASA is very
aware of the space junk problem the
question is what do you do about it
because think about this when you're up
in orbit above the earth you're talking
about an area that's actually larger
than the entire surface of the earth and
you're not only talking about an area
that extends up from the surface of the
earth but it extends up for hundreds of
miles
space junk is at many different
altitudes so there really isn't any way
to take a giant vacuum cleaner and just
start going after piece by piece of
space junk you would never cover that
amount of volume it would take you
centuries to even try so people are
talking about ideas like could you take
lasers could you maybe actually vaporize
some of the space dust how would you
clean it up could you actually unfurl
big sails that would sail around the
earth and scoop up some of the space
junk maybe but I for now haven't seen a
particularly good solution the best
solution is to try to put as little of
that stuff into orbit as possible and
know where the bigger pieces are and
right now we really have to manage the
problem more than solvent
[Music]